boy deserve ATS I wanted to spend time
with my children that was the starting
point every day life not just showing up
Friday evening and leaving again with
day Sunday real life like taking them to
kindergarten or school just everyday
activities I wish I'd had a year's
parental leave to one year for the
mother one for me or part-time work
until my daughter started school close
but his boss was against it this father
doesn't want to be identified because he
still fears repercussions two fathers in
Germany and their issues with
reconciling work and family York
Asmussen is a well-known economist he
worked for the Finance Ministry and was
involved in tackling the financial
crisis of 2007 he then moved to the
European Central Bank as a member of the
Executive Board the other gala but it is
a big I would have liked to stay at the
ECB it would have been fantastic doing
monetary policy for Europe the bank
would have been supportive and
understanding the problem was it's based
in Frankfurt and commuting was no longer
an option
once I had children damas or see a
client Kingdom so he resigned that
evidently touched a nerve bottle I was
surprised by the flood of emails and
posts they ranged from you're my role
model to you're an idiot
Hollywood more and more men in Germany
want to be closely involved in raising
their children many employers however
are dead set against that and create
obstacles our anonymous father is an
insurance agent he wanted to look after
his daughter when she was little but his
company refused to play along
the boss said no he was very disparaging
to the whole idea real men don't look
after kids that's women's work might as
well start wearing stockings it was
really nasty what a wuss to want to look
after your children his prejudices were
ironclad and antiquated they don't
belong in the present day and age but
that was no consolation since he had to
continue feeding his family he stuck it
out not everybody can just find another
job
I couldn't moving to a different
department would have been hard taking
parental leave only to face years of
punishment at work afterwards is not
such a great idea as to your caste misen
after he left the ECB he joined the
labor ministry in Berlin then he applied
for a job at the KfW Development Bank he
didn't get it he says the problem was
making time for his family
justice Kaffee career wise not getting
the job at the KfW was a setback I had
to start over it was frustrating but you
mustn't dwell on things like that but
move on I did find a good job with an
employer who understood that I was
serious about staying in Berlin because
of my children they said right away
we hear you hunger by engine first on
yeah
it's global this is like it's easier to
get to look after your kids if you're
quite high up in the hierarchy I think
it's even considered cool the question
is how can everybody get a chance to do
it with us for a little indie sweet our
other father was lower down in the
hierarchy there was no way around his
hostile boss I really regret it
I've missed out on this experience and
that can't be made good there's a hole
in my life I truly wish that every
father today could take the time to be
with his children
Lincoln's on with you
basically he was only around on the
weekends like many other fathers these
days however more fathers especially
younger ones are taking the time
especially ones with the means to do so
like doctors scientists people in
high-tech if their profession is in high
demand finding another job after timeout
is relatively easy even Travis is gone
by I just hope it becomes entirely
normal and nothing special for men as
well as women to be with the children
just part of life and the way we work at
least by the time my daughters are grown
up I'll buy that when Sundy kindig and
also of course sue in Germany fathers
currently take an average of three
months parental leave mother's 13 months